what was the idea that you and Karma of
alpha developed with a holographic
principle and string theory were we able
to discover through through this through
string theory about black holes or um
that connects us back to the reality of
black holes yeah so that is a very
interesting story I was
interested in black holes before I was
interested in
String Theory I was sort of
a reluctance
strength there is in the beginning I
thought I had to learn it because people
were talking about it but you know once
I studied it I I grew to love it first I
did it in a sort of dutiful way these
people say they've claimed quantum
gravity I ought to read their papers at
least
and then the more I read them the more
interested I got and I began to see you
know they
they phrased it in a very clumsy way the
description of string theory was was
very clumsy and mathematically clumsy or
just mathematically yeah
it was all correct but
but
mathematically clumsy but it often
happens
that in all kinds of branches of physics
that
um people start working on it really
hard and they sort of dream about it and
live it and breathe it and they begin to
see inner relationships and
they see a beauty that
is really there they're not they're not
deceived they're really seeing something
that exists but if you just kind of look
at it you know you can't you can't grasp
it all in the beginning and and um
so
our understanding of string theory in uh
uh in 1985 was almost all about uh you
know
weekly coupled waves of strings
colliding and so on we didn't know how
to describe
a big thing like a black hole and so you
know in string theory of course we could
show that strings in theory and some
limit reproduced Einstein's theory of
general relativity
and corrected it but we couldn't do any
better with black holes
then
um
before my work with Quran we couldn't do
any better than Einstein and Churchill
had done
now
um one of the puzzles
um you know if you look at the
Hawking's headstone and also Boltzmann's
headstone and you
put them together you get a formula
for their really Central equations in
20th century physics I don't
think there are many equations that made
it to headstones
and they're really Central equations and
you put them together and you get a
formula for the number of gigabytes in a
black hole
now a short shelves description
the black hole is literally a hole in
space and there's no place to store the
gigabytes
and it's not too hard to and this really
was wheeler and beckenstein and
wheeler beckenstein and Hawking
to come to the conclusion that
if there isn't a sense in which a black
hole can store
some large number of gigabytes
that quantum mechanics and gravity can't
be consistent
we've got we got to go there a little
bit so uh so how is it possible when we
say gigabytes there's some information
so black holes can store information how
is this thing that sucks up all light
and it's supposed to basically be you
know be super homogeneous and boring how
is that actually able to store
information where does the store
information on the inside on the surface
uh where where's yeah and what's
information
I'm liking this ask five questions to
see which one you actually answer oh
okay I should try to memorize them and
answer each one in order just to answer
them I don't know I don't know what I'm
doing I'm desperately desperately uh
trying to figure it out as I go along
here so um I
um
Black Culture shorts are black hole they
can't store information
stuff stuff goes in there and it just
keeps flying and it goes to the
singularity and it's gone
however Einstein's theory is not exact
it has Corrections
and string theory tells you what those
Corrections are
and so you should be able to find some
way of some alternate way of describing
the black hole that enables you
to understand
where the gigabytes are stored
so what Hawking and beckenstein really
did was they showed that physics is
inconsistent
unless
a black hole can store an a number of
gigabytes proportional to its area
divided by four times
Newton's constant times Planck's
Constant and that's another wild idea
you said area not volume
exactly
and that's the holographic principle the
universe is so weird and that's the
holographic principle that's called the
holographic principle that is it's the
area we're just jumping around what is
the holographic principle what does that
mean well is this some kind of weird
projection going on what what the heck
uh well I was just before I came here
writing an introduction to a paper in
the first sentence was
the
as yet imprecisely defined holographic
principle
blah blah blah so nobody knows exactly
what it is
but roughly speaking it says just what
we were alluding to that
um
really all the information
that is in some volume of space-time can
be stored on the boundary of that region
so this is not just about black holes
it's about any any areas based on any
air space however we've made sense of
the holographic principle for black
holes
we've made sense of the holographic
principle for something which could be
called anti-decider space which
could be thought of as a giant as the
black hole turned into a whole universe
and
um we don't really understand how to
talk about the holographic principle for
either flat space which we appear to
live in
or
asymptotically the sitter space which
astronomers tell us we actually live in
as the universe continues to expand
so it's one of the one of the huge
problems in uh physics is to
you know apply or even formulate the
holographic principle for
more realistic
well black holes are realistic we see
them but um
yeah in in more General context so from
a general statement of the holographic
principle